I'm excited that our talk here
and San Francisco is Mitch Altman.
Yay.
Uh,
is good for San Francisco taught cause
he embodies so many of those classic San
Francisco ideals of exploring
and experimenting and
being creative and figuring
out how to live a life
true to your ideals. Um,
so founder of Knightsbridge cofounder,
noise bridge or local epic hackerspace
and CEO of Cornfield electronics with all
these cool toys that people
here can play with after,
um,
take it away.
Great.
Thanks everyone for coming and hate
everyone who is watching remotely.
Hi. Um, I'm going to go
back to the slides now. Um,
so this is my contact info.
Please feel free to contact
me anytime for any reason.
I'm totally happy to help
any way I can always.
So,
um,
I'm going to be talking about a lot
of stuff that is totally my opinion.
Obviously. Even if it sounds
like I'm saying it emphatically,
it's still obviously just my opinion and
I don't expect everyone here to agree
with everything I say. But,
um, you know, we, we, we,
we can learn from the
experience of others for sure,
but in order to live a
life that each of us,
in order to live a life that
you feel is totally awesome,
you got to do things in
your own way. And, um,
and that's often not what a conventional
wisdom tells us is the thing to do.
Um, so yeah, so it's just my opinions. Um,
and my talk today is about doing things
together and it's really about community
and the need for community.
We can do so much on our own.
We've got big brains where
we got these big brains.
There are sometimes problematic,
but they're cool. Uh, we
can do a lot on her own,
but when we put our big brains together,
we create something way bigger,
way bigger than the sum of our parts.
And that's why we have, you know,
like companies and things. That's one
of the good things about companies.
There's a lot of things we can't do
on our own though. Um, like here's a,
some high school kids that I met in China,
uh,
who were invited there.
They knew nothing about all this physics,
but each person knew some things
and they had some mentors there.
And collectively knowing, starting
from nothing, they made a, um,
an atomic force microscope
out of Legos. And, um,
there's other things we
can't do on her own as well.
Like I'm having a pillow fight of
thousands of people in San Francisco,
which happens every year. Um,
lots of fun things. We do,
much more cool when we're together,
but we're not all that good at doing
things together on our modern world.
Um,
it's Kinda hard and that's because most
of us weren't fortunate enough to be
raised in a loving community where we
got all our needs are most of our needs
met, where we grew up, always knowing
that it's okay to be our own unique,
weird cells.
Most of us didn't have that,
but we need community
back at the beginning of our species,
we evolved coming together in community.
That's because we didn't have huge
muscles and big strength and scary roars.
Um,
we have big brains and we put our big
brains together and we support ourselves
in community. And, um,
even though I am back then,
we needed to do that in order to
survive in an often hostile environment,
need weed, even though now we
don't need that just to survive.
We do need that to feel part of
something bigger than ourselves,
to feel worthwhile,
to have thriving in our lives.
We need to feel we're part of
something bigger than ourselves.
We need that. And yet in our modern
world, there's so precious little of it.
So we just try looking
for it where we can,
we try getting it from our families
of origin. That works for some people.
That didn't work so well for me. Um, but
if it weren't for you, that's fantastic.
That's a great resource.
Um,
for many people they can find
it from their places of worship.
It also doesn't work for
me or we need people.
I know we try to create our own perhaps.
But you know, finding community is,
is difficult. Schools at their
best can give us some community,
but quite often the schools
are more like that. Um,
and then we try to find it at work.
Uh, Google I hope is better than this.
I don't know what you feel
like personally, but, um,
we try to find it at work and
we can get some there. But, uh,
we try to get it from TV.
That's one of my favorite things to hate.
Um,
here's a whole bunch of people alone
watching something seemingly together.
Um, and, uh,
the people on TV seemed to be friends,
but they don't even
know these people exist.
Therefore they can't care about it
and friends care about each other.
This is not community and the Internet,
we tried to get it on the Internet,
but the Internet usually like this.
We need it. We need community,
but we don't really have it. Uh,
I don't know about you, but like
as a geek, when I was a little kid,
it was dangerous to be a geek and I was
beaten up and bullied all the time as a
Geeky kid. And, um, every day
at school I was beaten up.
I did not have community.
I was terrified of humans because humans,
men's people who are going to beat me
up often while the gym teacher watched,
I don't know what it takes to
be a gym teacher, but uh, uh,
so my parents were no help. They
were just totally depressed too. Uh,
so my life was total hell as a kid
and when I got home I escaped into the
magical world of television.
Right. Tried to, anyways,
of course these things never work.
But um, as long as the TV show is on,
I could seemingly forget about my
horrible depressed existence. Um,
which made me more depressed because I
would compare myself to the kids on TV
who were beautiful,
had loving parents,
understanding friends and problems that
always resolved by the end of 30 minutes
show comparing myself to
that was horribly depressing.
I wasn't doing anything useful.
I wasn't going out and doing things.
I wasn't learning how
to deal with other kids.
I was eating junk food like
the commercials were telling
me to do and showing me
to do. And I wanted all these
toys that I couldn't get.
And I became more of a target because
I was fat and it totally unable to deal
with humans.
And I'm more of a targeted school only
to try to escape more in the TV when I
got home.
And that is addiction.
It was the first addiction of mine. I
became really good at addiction. Uh,
that's another story though. Um, but
I did eventually quit television,
um,
in 1980 and um,
I started doing all these things,
uh,
more of all these things that
I had already been doing,
like doing these geeky things,
which would really,
really cool and I could make all these
things and make things happen and I could,
uh, uh, I got really good at it.
I got really good at it enough
so that later in life, um,
I could become a consultant and help
small companies with their electronic
problems,
usually with little boards,
with microcontrollers and I did a
whole bunch of different things. Um,
and through the years,
um,
I eventually learned to live a life that
was appropriate for me and I was making
enough money doing consulting
for small companies,
doing lots of interesting things.
And I'll come back to that later because
it's relevant to what I'm going to talk
about with community and hackerspaces.
Um,
so the thing is we do
need to feel community.
We need to feel part of something bigger
than ourselves. And because of that,
we don't end. Since we don't have it,
we can be manipulated by this need.
And in our modern world,
there are all sorts of ways that were
manipulated in a grade school and high.
Unfortunately for adults
sometimes as well, um,
people band together and bullies,
they're afraid of the bullies.
Everyone's terrified of being
singled out by the bullies.
You don't want to be like
that, that little kid over
there who's being beaten up.
So quite often we join
in with the bullies.
It's not fun,
but people have to laugh at it anyways.
I don't know what football's all about.
Like it's totally like whatever.
But people seem to go into that and then
they start screaming the same thing at
the same time. They seem to
know it. They, when to do that.
I'll never understand that.
If that works for you, great.
But people aren't seem to be manipulated
with that sometimes too. And imagine,
you know,
you're in a big square where someone's
a really good speaker and everyone is
thrusting out little red books in
Tiananmen Square way back in the day.
That must have been really high.
Of course,
the end result wasn't so good.
It didn't end too well.
This also didn't end too well,
but it must have been super high to have
a million people in Nuremberg thrusting
out your arms this way.
Again,
people being manipulated by
our need for community. Um,
wars are also this many people after going
into a war of said it's the best time
of their life, not because they
love killing people necessarily,
but because they were emotionally
engaged and supporting each other for the
first time in their life.
But for this end,
we can do something
better than all of these.
I've been going to hacker conferences
since 2006 and giving talks small and big
and uh, workshops, small and big
and they are way more positive.
We can come together with our need
for being part of something bigger and
something that is inspiring,
something that helps people grow and
learn and do all sorts of cool things.
That one was in Brazil. This
is me teaching 50 people
how to solve the riddle,
a hacker conference in Germany.
It's at the end of December every year.
I know that's coming up this time. The
35th one they've been doing this a while.
They're really good at it.
It's, it's amazing. So anyways,
it's really cool and all I'm doing
is teaching them how to solder
big deal.
They're just melting a little bit of metal
and they can make a blinky light look,
they're happy.
All you have to do is bring people
together with something they feel is
enjoyable and people
have an enjoyable time.
Hacker spaces are the everyday,
every night version of this in your own
local area and there were thousands of
them in the world and
they do that really well.
So hackerspaces what are they?
Well,
they're way cooler than any
Internet meme you can think of.
There are physical places where people
come together and supportive community.
Everyone's encouraged to explore and
do what they find meaningful and doing.
That's it. It doesn't matter
what those activities are.
It's places where people do
this and it's super enjoyable.
It's really about the community.
Whatever the activities are is my, uh,
opinion is really just the excuse for
people to come together because we need
that. And when people are coming
together and a hackerspace,
they probably are going to come up with
all sorts of cool tools to do the things
that they want to try doing. And
um, there are a lot of cool tools,
but it's not about the tools.
Again, it's about the community.
Get that community. Okay. So, um,
but hackerspaces do come up
with lots of amazing tools,
all sorts of amazing things.
And people usually think that they
hear hacker space, maker space,
whatever they think of tech.
And there's plenty of tech to go around.
Lots of amazingly cool stuff.
And these are just some of the things
that I make to teach people electronics
and soldering. Excuse me. And uh,
but there's much more than that.
It was so many activities and depends
on the people who start and run a
hackerspace, what kind of activities go
on, which means what kind of tools or are,
and so there can be fabrication tools
for building amazing things with laser
cutters and three d printers and a wood
and metal and plastic. There can be,
uh,
all sorts of things for art
and craft like this or music.
Um, food, food hacking is amazing. Uh,
biology and science and math
and whatever people want to do.
But again, it's about
community. And here again,
some happy people who I'm
teaching to solder, they're happy
and it's for people of all ages,
old and young.
And it doesn't matter if people ever do
what I'm teaching them or anyone else's
teaching them. Just the act of
coming together inspires people.
And if they make something and it
does something they think is cool,
it gives people a sense of accomplishment.
It gives people a sense of confidence
that they bring forward for the rest of
their lives.
And who knows what people do with that
in their lives once they have that.
And um, yeah, it's amazing.
It's actually magic.
So I do want to mention that I'm calling
these things hackerspaces but people
can also call them makerspaces,
fab labs or whatever.
There are all these different names.
It doesn't matter which name you use,
as long as they're places where people
are supported by their community to
explore and do what they
think is really cool.
I like the word hacker space because
it's not about making a thing,
making a thing is great,
but it's much more than making a thing.
It's about coming together and
supporting each other and doing it.
Cause it's wonderful. I like
the word hacker space. Again,
it's the original words.
So that's the one I'm using and since
I'm using hackerspace and involves the
word hacking, again, there's
many definitions for this.
The word hacking was used
by the mainstream media to
talk about people breaking
into computers and stealing stuff.
That is not what we do at hackerspaces.
If anyone does that at hackerspace, uh,
and they get caught, they get booted.
So, um, it's not really helping
people to come together.
So hacking in my way of looking at it
is really seeing the world as full of
resources.
Our world is full of resources.
There's all sorts of things.
There's things we can buy,
there's things that other
people have thrown away.
There's all sorts of things we can use
and we can use them for any purpose we
want.
It doesn't have to be for the purpose
that it was intended for by the people or
companies that created it.
We can use all of this for our projects
to improve them. We can see what works,
what doesn't work,
and then we can learn from that
and share that with other people.
And that is what hacking is all about.
And that's the definition that was created
in MIT at the model railroad club in
1953 before people really
even heard of computers.
So it's not about computers,
it's a way of looking at things
and being a way of being.
And we do all of this because
it's incredibly enjoyable.
And if you're a geek like me,
we have to do this.
So it really is a way of living.
And that's another reason why I like the
word hacker space rather than just make
her space.
Um,
you don't have to be an
entrepreneur if you're a hacker. Um,
but if you're going to
be a good entrepreneur,
you do have to be a good hacker.
You must,
you must go out and see things and what
works and do things your own way and be
supported and share.
This is what makes a good entrepreneur.
And I'm going to mention something about
entrepreneurship because that's part of
hackerspaces not all of
it, but part of it. Uh,
and you've probably noticed that in our
world that there are a lot of startups.
Now we are in San Francisco where there
are a lot of startups and unfortunately
almost all of them are stupid.
I'll talk more about that later too.
So I am against stupid startups.
I want people to do something meaningful
and worthwhile and put that into their
world. So anyways, what can
be hacked? It's not just tech.
Of course there's tech
and electronics involved,
but there's art and craft and
music and science and yourself.
We need to hack ourselves.
We're going to improve and live our lives.
We need to hack our communities and
continually grow. See what works,
what doesn't,
and make our communities better.
We hack the planet because the
planet needs improvement as well.
Everything can be improved,
everything can and should be hacked.
Everything including education.
And this is one of the reasons why a
hacker spaces are getting so much, uh,
attention in the last many years and
why they've grown so much is because
they're fantastic learning environments.
Education doesn't have to look like this.
Education is not taking tests,
taking tests as about a
valuation of learning supposedly.
But now school is only about the test.
The thing you were supposed to
be having only for evaluation.
People are being trained
for taking the test.
That's like Volkswagen changing the test
for getting a good grade and their GPA
doesn't work.
All it does is make people into good
test takers if they're good at it.
So is this education?
Yes. Is it good education?
Now, can we do better? Absolutely.
If people are motivated to
learn than people learn.
Learning is fun.
We're doing this our whole lives.
If we go to a place like a hacker space
where people are being encouraged to
explore and do things that are meaningful,
that are fun and enjoyable than
we find projects that are cool.
And when we find a project
where we think is cool,
we want to learn as much as we can.
We're motivated to learn as much as
we can to make our projects awesome.
That's project based hands,
hands on, play based learning.
And this is why actually
schools are starting to put educate,
uh,
hackerspaces as part of their curriculum.
And schools and education
can look like this.
And in fact they are now more and more
education is about learning a lifetime of
learning. Cause we don't stop
learning once we get out of school.
If we stop learning once we got out of
the school, we just are waiting to die.
And there's nothing wrong
with waiting to die.
But life can be way cooler than that.
So it can be very fulfilling.
And maybe some of you have noticed that
we live in a society with capitalism.
Uh,
and with capitalism,
we have the absurd situation where you
have to have numbers on a screen or
fistful of dollars in order
to have food and shelter.
That's kind of bizarre, but it's true.
This is the way our planet is right now.
So in order to get this
money, what do you do? Well,
most people get a job and to have a job,
you go to work.
Some of you may have found a better
place than this, like I said,
but a lot of us on our planet, according
to the Internet where all truthfully,
80% of Americans don't like their work
and a good percentage of those hate their
work.
But I love my job.
I turn TVs off for living.
I created this device called TVB gone,
which is a key chain that turns
televisions off in public places.
And for the last 14 years,
I and 12 friends have
made a living on this. Um,
and uh,
I want to talk about a
bit about entrepreneurship
because this is another reason
why hackerspaces had been focused
upon a lot, uh, in the last few years.
And true partnership is not this.
It's not if you're going to be
a good intrepreneur anyways.
It's not about making money.
Most intrepreneur.
Most people that call
themselves an entrepreneur,
the first thing that I think
about is I'm going to make money.
How am I gonna make money?
I'll start a startup.
Yeah. What should the startup be? I
Dunno. A lot of people making apps.
Maybe I'm like an APP. Mine will
be orange, whatever. That's stupid.
Don't do that. Can do it if
you want to, but it's stupid.
You don't want to be stupid.
Do something cool.
Intrepreneurship can be and should be.
In my view,
creating meaning.
If you make time to explore and do
something you think is cool and you find
something cool and it's meaningful to
you and you think other people might like
it and they think it's meaningful,
those are the kinds of things and
capitalism that people will pay you to do.
And now you have a startup.
We're starting.
So back to my personal stuff here,
cause it's relevant again. You
know, I was, grew up depressed.
I escaped him to television. I learned
to be Geeky. I became a consultant.
I can make enough money in three months
to live the rest of the year without
working and I could do all these
other things that I loved. Um,
and it's all up for me
about doing things I love,
but I wasn't finding things I loved at
work. I would have things that were cool.
Like I was one of the people
who created virtual reality.
I worked on voice recognition,
a lot of um, uh, uh,
graphic stuff back when that was.
There were no graphics cards, uh,
lots and lots of interesting things,
but none of them made me jump
out of bed in the morning,
excited to face the day and solve the
problems that needed to be solved.
And it was just an okay way to make money.
Um,
so I actually quit doing that in 2003
so that I could run an experiment on
myself. I saved up enough money.
I was lucky enough to do that,
to live a year without working for money
and I would only do what I loved in
that here.
What would life be like if the only thing
you did for that whole year was what
you loved? Of course I still had
to do laundry for the most part.
I was just going to do what I loved
and if we're came along that I loved,
I would take it.
But it was kind of scary because I didn't
know if I would get any more work if I
kept telling people no, because I
didn't love what they were offering me.
But I did it anyways.
And I started working on all the,
I did volunteer work and
all these things I love,
but I started working on projects that I
had been thinking about but didn't have
time to work on because I'd
only been doing work, uh,
electronic work on all these
things for other people.
And I ran out of electronics
kind of energy. But, uh,
this one project that a I worked on that
really got on a roll was a result of
TV's popping up everywhere
in public places. Uh,
I quit TV in 1980.
My life suddenly had tons of time to
start facing the issues in my life.
To start doing things I thought were
worthwhile to learn how to handle dealing
with the weird, bizarre social
dynamics of human beings. And, um,
and it turns out I actually like humans.
They're my favorite species now. But, um,
uh, yeah. You know, whatever. Uh, I
had all this stuff going on in my life.
And suddenly in 1993 TV started
popping up everywhere in public places.
Some of you may not be old
enough to remember that
there was a time that TVs did
not exist in public places.
They were only in living rooms,
and they were expensive things,
and people saw a TV and a restaurant.
They thought that was an indication
of it being a dive. He horrible place.
But it started happening. And, uh,
it took me 10 years to get a place in
my life where I could start actually
working on this project. So this was in
2003. I was like, now I have the time.
I'm going to work on this project.
And I did.
And I did it because I
totally love this project.
It was meaningful for me because
this force that was totally,
uh, taken over my life when I was a kid
was starting to come back and I wanted to
get rid of it.
And so as a Geek I knew I could,
it's just a remote control with a bunch
of off codes. All of them I could get.
And it just plays one after
the other after the other.
And if you press the button
and make that happen,
eventually the TV in front of
you turns off. Totally simple.
I figured it would take about three weeks.
It took me a year and a half.
Projects always take longer than
you think they will should. Uh,
but I was obsessed with this
project and I got all the off codes.
I made them open source from,
no one ever has to do that ever again.
They're all online for free,
grab them, turn TVs off.
But I made TVB gone and um,
it was a work of love.
Bunch of friends helped me. Um, and uh,
I made one from my friends and we all
went all over San Francisco turning TV's
off in public places and it was really,
really fun.
And of course they told their friends and
many of their friends wanted it and it
turned out many of the
friends of the friends wanted
them. That's when I thought,
Gee, this thing that I just made one for
me and friends since they wanted them,
other people want to maybe,
maybe I could make a bunch because one
of the things I did as a consultant for
small electronic companies was
manufacturer things for them.
So I learned how to do that.
Maybe I could make some of these,
so I made as many as I could afford,
which was 20,000. Kind of a gamble,
but I did some math.
I figured if I did that,
then I could break even if I sold 5,000
of those 20,000 and if I sold any more
of those that would supplement my
income might take five or 10 years,
but whatever,
that would be cool.
There'd be five or 10,000 people going
all over the world. Turning TV's off,
that'd be pretty cool.
So I did that.
And then it turned out that I
was absolutely, totally wrong.
I sold all 20,000 in three weeks.
I was on National Public
Radio in New York Times, uh,
on people magazine. And, uh,
you know, Fox News. I went, uh,
I was brought in a limo from my apartment
in San Francisco to the Fox News,
um, um, uh, studios in
Oakland. And they said, well,
what your thing work online? 14 million
people watching. And the person asks me,
well, it turn off these monitors here in
our studio. And I'm like, I don't know.
Let's see.
And I do it.
And I pushed the button and all of them
turn off and then the whole place like
the gasps and then they
start laughing and um, yeah.
And then afterwards,
one of the people at a Fox where
it's kind of like looking around
okay. And the kind of like, ah,
I agree with you.
And the odd thing is 10 minutes later,
another person that didn't know
that other one did the same thing.
So how many people at Fox?
Or actually uh, yeah, phone.
So anyways,
that was 2004 when I put that
out and here I am 14 years later
and um, that's the only way I've
made money in the last 14 years.
Me and 12 friends for 14 years have made
a living on this project we think is
really cool.
Really awesome.
A project we love and that brings
me to my definition of success
is that success?
No,
it's a pile of money.
Piling money is not success and
pilot money is just a pile of money.
My definition of success is this.
If your explore and do what you love
and you find something you love and it's
meaningful and you put it out there in
whatever way and other people think it's
meaningful and they're paying you to do
it, you get enough of whatever you need,
including money to keep doing what
you love. What more do you need?
What more do you need?
If you spend even two seconds
more making money beyond that,
you are wasting your time.
Why are you doing that?
So
community is what makes all
of this really possible.
I wouldn't have been able to
do TV gone just on my own. Um,
maybe it would have taken way, way,
way longer. But I did it way, way,
way better because I had a community
of friends with hackerspaces.
Now we don't have to be lucky enough
to have the friends with all these
different skills.
People with those skills are in
our community at our hackerspaces.
We can do lots together and we
need to have people together.
We can do it so much better together.
But often we needed, you know,
like Linux wouldn't have
happened no matter how
brilliant Linnaeus was, his, um,
and three printers was an international
project and all these things,
we do so much better when we put
people together and inspire each other.
And this is what maker fairs were about.
And the first one in 2006 people who
found community with the projects they do
and showing them off.
But this is what's been going on with
hacker conferences for decades now.
And my first hacker conference
I was invited to because
a of TVB gone and it was
amazing. Thousands of people, almost
all of whom do what they love,
which makes it super high way,
unfortunately different than
society at large. And I loved that.
And when the conference was over,
I wanted more,
but I had to wait until my next
conference and it was high again.
And that was the one in Germany.
And um,
and I've been going to these and I've
been helping organize this one ever since
hope hackers on planet earth. Um, and um,
uh, by my third one, it was
just the coolest thing. I mean,
they had a fan of spaceship and I taught
people to solder and they of course had
lasers and hundreds of talks,
one of which was how to
start your own hacker space.
And that inspired me and several of my
friends from various parts of the US to
start hackerspaces and
we all helped each other.
And we got help from the Germans who
had been looking around and seeing what
works and what doesn't
work at hackerspaces there
for the last many years.
And we started the early hacker spaces.
Some of the early hackerspaces is in
the u s a Noisebridge in San Francisco.
This was in 2007 hack DC in Washington,
DC and NYC resistor in New York City.
Um,
and when we did that in 2007,
there were about 40 hackerspaces
and now there's thousands.
And this is actually an old picture.
China is now just as obliterated with
pins for hackerspaces as the rest of the
world. And this is from
hackerspaces.org, uh,
are organizing websites that we created
to help people start hackerspaces.
And the thing is,
hackerspace is still all help each other.
If anyone wants to start one,
there's always people to help
and we all help each other.
Each one's unique though.
There's no central Church of hackerspaces.
Each one can organize themselves any
way they want and help each other.
And there's lots of them all over the
world. There's noise. Bridge is Tokyo.
Here's a few in Belgium and these are all
ones where I've been. And last year, um,
just random ones, I've been to hundreds
and hundreds is more in Belgium.
I'm more in Belgium. That's in
Brazil. Sao Paolo. Uh, London,
uh, Zagreb, Croatia, where I was
a hacker in residence this year.
Tommy one in Tel Aviv or I
was a hacker in residence.
These are all me giving workshops,
soldering,
but of course things go on besides
just soldering. That's just pictures.
I've got a Urbana Illinois where I was
a hacker in residence, a Shinto, Jen,
a hackerspace, the coolest one in China,
the first one in China, two in Shanghai.
But there are lots of cool places
in China once for just little kids.
This is university Ching Hua University.
Uh,
Shen Jen do DIY.
They have things for little kids and
all people of all ages. A Chihuahua, uh,
is a way cool place in Shenzhen as well.
And um,
the head of state of China visited them
in 2015 while all of Chinese media with
hundreds of millions of people watching,
visited this space and said
that this hackerspace is,
are the future of China for education,
for economic development and personal
growth. And I'm not to be outdone,
uh, our president at the
time did that too. Um,
although not hundreds of millions of
people watching. Um, but after this,
all bureaucrats all over the world
knew that they must start hackerspaces.
Unfortunately,
they don't know what they are and
they make places that look like this,
which is kind of a waste.
But those could get filled up
with people doing cool things. Um,
if there's a community
that can make that happen.
I don't want to say that
community is hard work.
We're not good at this stuff, but
we got to get better at it. Uh,
if we want to have communities that
are worth having. And um, yeah.
Um, I'm actually no longer part of noise
bridge because of some of the serious
problems there. And I thought
I could have, uh, you know,
use my energies for something
more positive for me. Um, yeah.
And that saddens me. But,
um, I do wish everyone,
they're the best,
but community is very rewarding.
It's very rewarding.
And it's what's been driving me is
helping communities around the world.
And that's what I do.
And one of the things I do is I travel
all over the planet and I want to hammer
this in for anyone watching.
So you do this,
you out there, listen to
this. Okay, great. Okay,
so entrepreneurship doesn't have
to be about just making money.
You need to make enough
money to make it all work.
Of course we have a capitalist society,
but entrepreneurship for it to work
has to happen this way in this order.
First you make time and then you explore
and you find things that you think are
cool. You keep trying things, you try it
out. Some things work, some things don't.
You keep learning from successes,
from failures.
You'll learn way more from
failures because we fail a
lot more than we succeed.
But we learned from all of this and
you keep trying again and again.
It's a roller coaster. There's ups,
there's downs, it's okay, you keep going.
You're driven by it because it's awesome,
it's cool and eventually
you find something you love
that's meaningful for you.
It's meaningful for others.
Now you have something that's worth
starting because people will pay you for
something they find meaningful and
now you have a startup that has some
possibility for success.
Unfortunately on our planet right now
and here in Ground Zero San Francisco,
it's mostly driven by investors who
don't care about anything except making
money for themselves.
No matter what they say.
And they believe the
lies as they say them.
So if you have an FVC of
vulture capitalist, sorry,
venture capitalist, um,
don't believe their shit.
They believe it,
but you don't have to,
they want you to have an exit strategy
before you even start and they want you
to become the next apple
and the next Google.
There already is an apple and a Google.
I don't think the world needs another one.
Some people might argue that we
already have one to many of edge.
I'm not saying where I
stand there, but um, uh,
I'm very happy to be here at
one of these corporations, uh,
who is doing at least some
good things in the world.
We also don't need to grow.
Growing is not always good,
okay?
We don't have to grow.
We just have to have a sustainable
business so that the people who are in it
find what they do meaningful and
by doing what they find meaningful,
get enough of what they
need to keep doing it.
What would your life be
like if you were doing that?
Maybe you aren't doing that here.
What would the world be like if there
were hundreds of millions of these kind of
small sustainable businesses,
most of which don't grow,
some of which become popular and they
need to and they want to make whatever
they have available to warn more
people and so they can grow in.
Some investors might even
make money from it, fine,
but what would the world be like if there
were hundreds of millions of these and
it wasn't 80% of people
who didn't like their jobs,
but 80% of people who did and what if a
huge percentage of those loved what they
were doing in the world with a
third of their life going to work?
I think the world would be a way
more amazing place than it is now.
Hackerspaces are one way to do this
because there are places where people come
together and are supported by their
community to explore and do these kinds of
amazing things.
We need these not just hackerspaces
about community and all sorts of ways.
And I encourage you all to do that because
if we wait for our governments to do
that, we are all going to be
dead. But while we're alive,
we have the opportunity to do cool things
for ourselves and the people around us.
So I encourage you all tend to that.
And if I can help in any way,
let me know.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Um,
we have one question. Um, the dory from
New York, from Leo. Hi Mitch.
I remember reading about your brain
machine device back in make magazine at
least 10 years ago now
that some time has passed.
What updates would you make
for 2018 and beyond, if any?
Well, a lot of things I've been
playing with uh, brainwaves, um,
stuff all my life as an Undergrad,
I,
I was a Guinea pig for
a psych experiments, uh,
physiological psych experiments. Uh,
back then you had to have things,
Gulu deer skull and uh,
uh, but it was cool.
You could read your brain waves.
Um,
and people have been recording
brainwaves since 1928. Uh, and, uh,
the brain machine came just
to sort of this flash rains,
great inspiration when
I was meditating ones.
And I thought what would happen
if you played brainwaves back?
And it turns out when I
started researching that
the people have been playing
them back ever since they started
recording them in 1928. Um,
so I made brain machine has a simple
thing to encourage people to try to make
something if they've never made anything
before. And it was super popular. Uh,
what made it super popular is that it
blinks lights. Um, the way it works,
it blinks lights and make sound
at a sequence of meditation,
brainwave sequence frequencies.
And if it works for you,
your brain just sort of syncs up to
it and you follow along and then you
meditate.
Um,
but what makes it super popular is that
your brain doesn't know what to do with,
uh, the blinky light information that
feels fills your whole field of vision.
Um, and so since it doesn't understand
what to do, it make stuff up.
That's what our brains do when
something doesn't make sense,
which explains a lot of
our politics. Um, but uh,
what you make up when you're
doing the brain machine is, uh,
you draw from your imagination and your
experience and you see beautiful wild
colors and patterns.
And it turns out a lot of people
actually like hallucinating. So, uh,
it's been a popular project for a long
time and I'm not the only one who makes
things like this. I just made one that
was really cheap and easy to make. So, um,
what I've been wanting to do and have
been playing with is having input as well
as output.
So if you have EEG,
that's the way to measure brainwaves.
Uh, there's cheap ones now.
There's open source ones. A friend of
mine is working on one called brain,
we know works on an Arduino. Um,
it's $250. And it works great.
So if I have that,
then it can be reading my brainwaves as
of the blinking lights on the sound are
trying to get me to the state that I want.
It can be seeing if it's working and it
can alter it and then get me to where I
want to be rather quickly. Um, yeah. So
that's, that's what I've been working on.
And then there's this other thing here.
Um,
I had a Kickstarter for this a long
time ago and it's gets kind of weird,
but it's like a brain machine,
but it's way nicer
sound and a more gentle,
you don't hallucinate,
but it has a 20 minute sequence to bring
you to the point of falling asleep to
help people sleep. So, uh, yeah, I put
a lot of time and energy into that. Um,
the Kickstarter was successful,
but since then, marketing,
this has just been really difficult.
So this hasn't really gone to many places,
but I'd love to add, um, uh,
EEG to that and play around with that.
Right.
Hi there.
Okay.
Good question for you about makerspaces
and other communities like that. Um,
can you comment a little bit about
best practices to make them work? Um,
I noticed you highlighted Noisebridge
where there were some difficulties,
but what,
what are,
what does successful makerspaces do
to make the community grow and thrive?
Uh, that's a big question. Um,
and it's unique to each space,
but there's a few things that are,
um,
probably common for all the
ones that are working. Uh,
of course you need to have a business
model so that you get more, uh,
resources in. Then you use a, and that
definitely includes money on our planet,
but they're all at a hacker spaces that
are, uh, there were more in the past,
but that our squats and they need very,
very little money.
But you need a bunch of, um, uh,
you need a space otherwise
not a hacker space. Um,
and um,
yeah,
so there has to be some kind of model
for bringing more resources and then you
spend,
you also have to have a way to organize
yourselves so that everyone who's part
of the organization feels like this
is a great way to organize ourselves.
A way of having decision making that
everyone involved feels heard and um,
feels valuable.
You have to have ways of having conflict
resolution because when you have more
of one or more humans in room,
there will be strife. Um,
and uh,
we need to have ways that are worthwhile
to resolve the conflicts when people
have conflict and it's always going
to happen. Uh, if you resolve them,
that brings people closer.
If people don't,
there's like just a little thing,
I'm going to ignore it.
Then it builds up and
people have resentments.
We've all had this with boyfriends,
girlfriends or whatever. Um, and um,
yeah. Uh, it builds and resentments build.
We have to have ways to encourage people
to bring things up while they're little.
That's not easy. We're all
trained, especially, uh,
in our modern America to not say things
we know people don't want to hear,
but it's super important.
We need to learn to do these things.
Otherwise people just end up drifting
away rather than staying in a place that
it's challenging. Um,
also, this is a hard part.
It's not the fun part
of having any community.
You need to kick out people who aren't
working, you give him plenty of chances,
you know, you don't want to just
go, oh, you cross the unwritten law,
now you're out of it. Sorry. Um,
give people a chance to change their
behaviors and do it in a way that people
feel good. You've got a, I'm
doing in a way that's uh,
and Noisebridge we have only one rule
and that's be excellent to each other.
Um, yeah. If someone's
not being excellent,
it's not okay to be mean to them.
That's not excellent.
So if someone's not doing things in
a way that fit in with the community,
give them plenty of chances and learn
from them as well because that can be
pointing out something that's not
working well in your community.
But we really nice to them and
polite, assertive, of course. Um,
and resolve the issues. Again,
that's a broad generalization, but,
and it's not easy. It's easy
to say. It's super difficult.
That's one of the most difficult
parts of being in any community or any
relationship, but it's
way worthwhile. So, um,
yeah, those are some of the things you
have to have activities that people in the
community wants to do.
And you have to encourage people.
Everyone has to encourage each other to,
uh,
put a little bit more past their comfort
zone into activities so that people
have an exciting environment come in.
The ideal if the hacker spaces a place
where people can just pop in any time and
something cool will be happening.
And then more and more people come more,
which makes more and more cool people
come and more people are doing more cool
things, which make more people come
because there's cool things happening,
et cetera.
So.
Okay.
That was all kind of vague.
I know.
But if you have any specifics
I can address those.
Um,
so I'm interested to hear your thoughts
on how we can improve diversity in our
hackerspaces.
Uh,
they do tend to be very white and a lot
of white privilege people are the people
who are participating in them. Not 100%,
but, uh, you know, I'm interested to,
you know, how can we change that and
how can we make it more, you know,
diverse from a neurodiverse race,
gender thought problem,
religion, politics, whatever.
Yeah. Um, not all hackerspaces
feel that's super important.
Uh, I knew, um, and at noise
bridge at the very beginning,
we wanted it to be as, uh, you know,
ideally to reflect the
demographics of San Francisco. Uh,
that hasn't happened.
People who are white and
middle or upper class,
certainly I've more
opportunities and advantages
and privileges and other people.
So,
um,
people in that class have
more time and also have, um,
the ability to take for doing
something like this. Um,
but given that, um, myself
included in that class, um,
have this opportunity and the privilege,
we can share that with others
and encourage others to join us.
So at the beginning of noise
bridge, um, it was, um,
probably about 40% female and 6%
male and a handful of other genders.
And,
um,
we wanted to encourage people to join us
in order to ensure that there was more
gender balance. We started
doing things from the beginning,
getting the tools together so that there
were like traditional whatever to call
it, things that are roles for
females like sewing and craft.
Um, and what we found
is really quickly, uh,
since sewing stuff's over here
in soldering, is over here,
electronics and there's other
things in fabrication all around.
It's just one big open space.
Everyone just starts in your mixing
and there's no solid separation anyways
between electronics and art
and electronics and sewing
or sewing and fabrication
of other things. So, uh, and there's
certainly no wall that prevents,
uh, someone of one gender going
here or another gender going there.
And there's nothing about a human brain
regardless of gender that says whether
you can or cannot hold a soldering iron
or can or cannot put fabric through a
sewing machine.
Um,
so doing these things that have been
traditionally for one gender and making
sure that they're there,
especially for the genders that you
would normally be underrepresented, uh,
has been really good way at hackerspaces
around the world to get more diversity
in a positive way.
And not just saying having a quota
because that doesn't seem to work.
Um, and uh, at, um,
artisan's asylum in Boston,
there was a woman who was super great at
a welding and she started a class that
was really popular for awhile. Maybe
it still is a called welding for girls.
And uh, that was a way to get a whole
bunch of women in who might not have come
otherwise.
Uh,
San Francisco is a pretty diverse
set of different peoples. Uh,
noise bridge is in the mission,
which is a, was until recently,
mostly Hispanic. And yet there aren't
many Hispanic people at noise bridge.
And we've been rather unsuccessful
at getting a Hispanic people in,
which it's unfortunate there's
been a number, but um, you know,
cause we want it to be welcoming for
everybody. So, but we keep trying,
you know,
we have the broader problem of our planet,
the way it is and the way it
has been for thousands of years.
So we're not going to solve all the
problems right away with just one
organization. But we can try things,
see what works and what doesn't.
Share it with others,
learning from others of what works and
doesn't work from them and keep trying to
make it better. And as long as we
keep doing that, it does get better.
Yeah.
I think we're out of time,
but if you have more time or
have decided to quit your job,
do what you love all day. Um, we,
last night we just decided to have this,
uh,
ad hoc up kind of hacker space setting
and we have luck picking sets to play
with and we have matches kits to play
with and we have San Francisco maker space
represented to play with. So, uh,
stay and play and we can have a
little San Francisco community.
Is it okay if I take a picture of the
audience? Anyone care? Okay, cool.
Hi Roland.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thanks.